das geld was hätte ich gerne wirst du es
neben den immer hin wollte das live
fleischverbrauch fleischer gebraucht um
sie ab heute gute ja weil ich
potenzieller putenschnitzel das ist
jetzt nicht weil das ist schon eine
insel der ruhe ist aktuell oder filet
oder schnitzeln geschnitten hätten auch
vielleicht mal wacker nach das kabinett
gute hat seine mutter gesagt mutter
gesagt
das ist auch nicht anders
muss vielleicht zu ich muss meinen kids
vom kindergarten
im kindergarten ist ihr enkel sei aber
seien sie nachher zum ich habe sie doch
noch vor vier wochen erst wurde ist und
wo haben sie vorher pump gelebt dann
königssee könig cie
das heißt dass ein wunderbares essen
geben region königssee das waren
ja
bis nach herborn na dann
machen sie urlaub am königsee wir haben
das schönste echo der welt
[Applaus]